urged to stay indoors many have been
unable to share the joys of spring the
season forever lost but also worn which
is looking and sounding slightly
different it's not your imagination the
birds are louder one of the more
noticeable impacts of lockdown this is a
nature reserve in the West Midlands run
by the RSPB small changes are already
being noticed by staff around the
country just on some of our nature
reserves we're seeing that birds are
changing their nesting behavior a little
bit they're nesting much closer to
footpaths and busiest spots than they
would have done before when visitors
were there and second of all lots of
people from the public are getting in
touch asking why they can hear more
birds
why birdsong seems so loud and that's
for two reasons so first of all the
birds are competing with less air and
road traffic noise and secondly we're
just taking the time to stop and take
notice and listen and obviously it's
spring time the birds are getting really
busy and singing a lot more it's not
just nature lovers making the most of
the great outdoors stargazers are having
a field day - with less pollution comes
a better view of the sky at night
astronomers have been reveling in clear
images of the Llyod meteor shower I
really hope that what we see now with
the renewed interest in stargazing that
we're going to see that last thing after
this period has passed and that we will
in some sense reclaim the sky and across
the world
a planet in pandemic paralysis is
looking different from the Italian city
of Milan an unusually clear view of the
Alps this is the impact of six weeks of
lockdown over Venice
the slowdown in the industrial
powerhouse of China has also resulted in
brighter skies and whilst were all
indoors
they've been glimpses of animals
reclaiming the streets from kangaroos in
Australia to wild boar in Israel closer
to home
goats in Wales audacious in the places
they now roam in Essex the locals were
seen making friends with deer one way
round the lockdown rule to hang out only
with people from your own household Lisa
Holland Sky News